you're going to begin with breaking news
and it's breaking news of the positive
sort for a change a tentative deal to
prevent a potential economic crisis a
deepening one in any case just hours ago
President Biden announced that after
intense negotiations a tentative
agreement was reached between Railway
companies and unions an agreement that
could avert a strike that would have
severely affected already fragile Supply
chains Ed O'Keefe is following all this
news this morning from Alexandria
Virginia for us add a lot of items that
Americans use every day come on trucks
and then trains good morning what do we
know about this deal
Good morning Tony nice to start with
some encouraging news and it means that
train stations like this one outside
Washington will continue operating as
normal announcement of a tentative deal
came after 20 hours of consecutive
face-to-face talks at the labor
department in Washington President Biden
announcing the deal earlier this morning
saying in a statement these rail workers
will get better pay improve working
conditions and peace of mind around
their health care costs all hard-earned
a handful of the Dozen railroad unions
have been holding out for a better
agreement on sick leave they had until
tonight at midnight to reach a deal or
cause a nationwide strike that would
have affected almost 7 000 trains across
the country I should point out this is a
tentative agreement giving the Union
several more weeks to make sure the deal
is ratified and avoid a national
shutdown but as you mentioned this
averts what could have been a
significant supply chain crisis for the
already stretched Trucking and shipping
Industries one Industry Group warned it
could have cost about two billion
dollars in Lost productivity Nate good
thing we're going to avoid that
you're right about that Ed thank you